if you want to hear the details about
Patrick's life that had to be taken out
of the movies because they were way way
too dark for audiences and stick around
to the end of this video I wasn't
planning on doing another ish character
on horror history at least not for a
while but I got so many requests to
cover Patrick hochstätter the twisted
preteen with no sense of morality making
him the scariest human character in the
novel one thing that Stephen King makes
note of is the fact that Patrick's
behavior probably would have been picked
up on by child psychologists had he been
born in a later era so in today's
episode we'll attempt to analyze Patrick
with a psychological lens to fully
understand him we've got to first take
it back to his childhood
Patrick hochstätter was born in 1946 as
the son of a paint salesman Patrick's
father and Patrick's mother who was only
described as being a devout Catholic
Patrick was a plump boy with a perfectly
round pallid moon face is much different
than the slender looking Hot Topic
version of Patrick from the theatrical
version patrick developed a psychiatric
condition called Salafism syndrome which
is when a person feels that there's no
reality beyond their own mind
Patrick believed that he was real but
that he was the only real person nobody
but him actually existed they were just
figments of his own mind the novel never
explains how Patrick developed this
disorder but I would guess that it may
have been related to the birth of his
younger brother Avery in late 1950
because Salib sysm syndrome has been
associated with periods of extended
isolation most often diagnosed in
astronauts left alone for long missions
in outer space
perhaps when Avery was born he commanded
all of mr. and mrs. Hawks adders
attention and left Patrick feeling
isolated maybe even neglected and due to
his young age he was only 5 at the time
the effects of solipsism set in more
quickly Patrick did not like when every
was brought home from the hospital he
claims not to care if his parents had
more kids as long as his schedule was
not interrupted and he began to feel
jealous as his meals started coming in
late and Avery's crying kept him awake
at nights as his parents constantly
tended to the newborn it is not known to
what extent his parents neglect reached
but Patrick did begin to fear that Avery
would replace him so he took matters
into his own hands one day when he came
home from kindergarten his father was at
work and his mother was napping so he
wandered in Avery's room what the
five-year-old Patrick did next is
considered to be one of the most
disturbing chapters in all of Stephen
King's writing he started by turning
Avery's head into the pillow
he stood there and watched him struggle
for air for five minutes before Avery
managed to turn his head back up then he
tried holding Avery's face down into the
pillow testing if the baby snorts for
air would wake up mrs. Hawkes Tedder
they didn't so he decided to press
Avery's face down into the pillow full
force and did not let go the feeling of
doing this excited Patrick in a way that
he had never felt before
after the deed was done he casually
strolled downstairs and made himself a
plate of cookies with a glass of milk
when his mother woke up she came
downstairs before checking on Avery
thinking that he was still asleep
Patrick showed her the drawing he had
made at school which was just a chaotic
mess of black and brown scribbles he
told her it was a house in a tree he
would bring home the same mess of
scrolling lines every day each time
telling her that it's something else
these drawings are never really
explained but they may be an indicator
of Patrick's stalled development in
response to his solecism as children age
they not only physically developed a
grouping babies two kids two teens two
adults but there's also an emotional
development taking place however if a
child had solipsistic Patrick he never
makes those emotional connections with
other humans because he believes that he
is the only human so he becomes a
sociopath children's drawings are one
way that they're able to express their
emotions from a young age such as two or
three they may express themselves more
through the process than the final
product so if they're trying to draw a
car then they might scribble a bunch of
fast lines across the page but by age
five they're able to understand how to
create shapes and somewhat realistic
proportions because their motor skills
have developed and they've emotionally
developed and want to make something
more complex but in Patrick's case he
hasn't emotionally evolved at all
probably not since his parents started
thinking about having a second child
mrs. Hawkes Tedder was worried by his
disturbing artwork but she just told
herself that he would grow out of it and
tried to ignore the problem she didn't
discover Avery's death until 5 p.m. when
she went to check on his unusually
lengthing that Patrick sat watching TV
through the uproar of screaming and
crying that followed the doctor came at
some point to see if there was any
chance to save Avery and when he saw
Patrick's nonchalant reaction he assumed
that he'd gone into some kind of state
of shock and gave him a pill for its the
incident was diagnosed as a crib death
there was a moment where mr. hochstätter
noticed what looked to be Patrick's
snowy footprints in Avery's room and
almost put two and two together
but then forced himself to push that
thought away but perhaps what has really
chilled readers is that over the
meaning seven years of Patrick's life he
felt no shame no guilt and experienced
no nightmares over what he had done in
1951 he began his first attempt at first
grade he was seeking to recapture the
feeling that he enjoyed so much that he
discovered at the side of Avery's crib
so he started a little collection in his
pencil box he would kill flies and
torture beetles and keep them in this
box it was a microcosm for another
distressing habit from later in his life
involving a refrigerator at the dump on
the way home one day he discovered a
dying cat that had been run over an old
woman caught him poking at it and told
him off if only he had lived a little
way down the road over in Ludlow man he
would have loved it over there Patrick
was forced to repeat the first grade
during the 1951 1952 school year but the
following summer on a family trip he
would discovered the only semblance of a
true fear that he would ever encounter
[Music]
in August of 1953 the hochstätter family
visited brewster lake one day when
Patrick was swimming out in the lake he
got out to discover leeches stuck to his
body
not those leeches the other ones leeches
are the blood sucking worm parasite
found in some freshwater lakes Patrick
did not like the idea of having his
blood sucked because it reminded him of
his mortality and he believed he could
not die because he was the only real
person so he screamed and screamed until
his dad pulled off the lesions this was
the one and only thing that ever scared
him and it's described in the book as a
wretched loathing Patrick managed to get
through second grade on one try but the
same could not be said about third grade
with mrs. Wayans as he got older his
strange behavior became more and more
apparent
mrs. Weems knew about the pencil box
filled with flies whose wings had been
removed by Patrick but he was quiet and
didn't really have any disruptive
disciplinary issues so it was easy for
him to fly under the radar compared to
kids like Henry Bowers who would disrupt
class and start fights that's not to say
that Patrick had no issues sometimes he
would turn in his tests completely blank
or just with a large question mark like
Nathan explosion during his GED hair
okay
it's a zero no questions were answered
oh damn seriously how could you have not
known that so he had to repeat the third
grade as well because he had some bruce
bochy even here magic in him because he
managed to pass the fourth grade and
then it was in the fifth grade in
October of 1957 but he made one major
upgrade to his pencil box hobby by
finding an abandoned refrigerator in the
dump and made it his new experimentation
lab he would kidnap the pets of
neighbors in a cardboard carton and
bring them to the refrigerator to do
horrible things to them all in the name
of recapturing the feeling he'd gotten
on Avery's final afternoon he captured
several pets and strays over the course
of the next eight months discarding the
bodies in the bushes after he was
through with them but as his need for a
fix increased he started to suspect that
somebody knew what he was doing the
fridge grew a power over him he seems to
develop some kind of ritual associated
with opening it he's only seen once by
Beverly Marsh from a distance and
described as a swaying motion like a guy
in a horror movie trying to summon a
dead body out of the crib do it
fantasize about the fridge during the
day drawing pictures of it in school and
dreaming of it during the night in one
dream the fridge was huge and he opened
it to find a pair of eyes staring at him
this may be related to his worry that
somebody knew about it when he ran out
of pets to torture he moved on to
pigeons and other animals that he could
find to satisfy his craving in fifth
grade he had mrs. Douglas and she had to
deal with some new problems that his
previous teachers had nods she kept him
away from girls on the seating chart
because of his tendency to get hands
Beverly was one of the girls who had to
experience this all at once you'd feel
this hat almost as light as a feather
but it was warm and sweaty meaty
I mean penny wise is pretty scary dude
but I'm starting to think he's got
nothing on a meaty hands hochstätter
over here I mean what do you even have
to do to get your hands to feel meaty
and the worst thing the horrible thing
was the way that he'd smile and never
say anything mrs. Douglas knew Brenda
Bowie told on him and I think Sally
Mueller said something wants to but I
think mrs. Douglas was scared of him too
needless to say Patrick did not pass the
fifth grade
[Music]
perhaps it was this fear that mrs.
Douglas had of him that was the reason
he was allowed to take summer school
rather than repeating yet another grade
but these summer classes did not stop
him from terrorizing the kids of Derry
during July of 1958 not only had Patrick
reached full fledged psychopath status
by now but he was also spending his free
time around other troubled kids and had
become a member of Henry Bowers feared
gang of bullies on July 20th they were
chasing down a boy named Eddie kasparek
Henry was desperate for revenge on Eddie
for the part that he played in a rock
fight earlier that summer when they
caught up with him Patrick who had no
real beef with Eddie but just enjoyed
causing others to feel pain slapped his
face on both sides
Henry ended up breaking Eddie's R and
when police sirens could be heard in the
distance they decided to split before
running for it Patrick left Eddie with a
little parting gift by spitting in his
face this was the ultimate attack when
it comes to Eddie who was a known
hypochondriac in germophobe
I imagine Patrick took great pleasure in
what would be taken is such a hurtful
act later that month
Patrick is hanging out with the Bowers
gang again and suggests that they go to
the dome they all have their pants
around their ankles as they try to
ignite their farts with the lighter
after some time Henry's minions belch
and Victor have to leave so just Henry
and Patrick remain henry takes a turn
being the fuel source and Patrick he
gets too close and burns his exhaust
pipe and he gets pissed
Patrick offers to show something to
Henry telling him it will feel good so
he ends up giving him a hand and also
gives himself a hand at the same time
they're both enjoying themselves
so Patrick offers to take it a step
further by doing a little pipe cleaning
and Henry kind of realizes what he's
gotten himself into and lashes out and
knocks Patrick to the ground telling him
that he doesn't go for any of that stuff
they argue over whether or not Henry
liked it and Patrick had a crazy smile
until Henry dropped a bombshell that
would make one of Patrick's biggest
worries come true
[Applause]
[Music]
after the pipe examination incident
Henry threatens Patrick to try to get
him to stay quiet about it and Patrick
basically blackmails him asking for $1
in exchange for silence but little does
he know Henry has a counter of his own
saying if hochstätter tells he'll tell
everyone about what Patrick doesn't the
refrigerator and get him thrown in a
mental asylum this is the only time in
the book where Patrick sounds kind of
scared while he responds not the same
fear as his fear of the leeches but more
of a worry about getting cause because
he knows that breaking the rules means
consequences with that Henry leaves
forgetting to take with his lighter as
he did so
Patrick continued to sit there for the
next five minutes playing with the
lighter and still at his ankles you
think someone who's afraid of leeches
might also be a little conscious about
tics but apparently not a few minutes
later he returns to the refrigerator to
check on a pigeon he'd caught two days
before he wanted to discard the corpse
because of Henry's threat and perhaps
clean out the inside of the fridge as
well just in case when he opened the
door he saw that the pigeon was all
skeletal the meats was completely picked
off of its bones and the inner walls of
the fridge were covered in small flesh
colored creatures that Patrick thought
looked like macaroni shells one of these
creatures latched on to his arm and
slowly turned red he didn't think it was
harmful because he still believed it was
not real but then he came to a
realization about what they were some
kind of flying leeches his worst fear
but was wings yeah that's that that's
pretty scary to think about it he
screamed and swatted at the thing which
was growing in size and it burst it was
a his horror the head remained intact
and was still clenched to his arm he had
to pry the thing off using his fingers
which is actually what you're supposed
to do then the other leeches flew out of
the fridge and attacked him as usual he
felt no pain just a draining sensation
and stark terror one flew down his shirt
another landed on his eye and began
draining its fluids one once inside of
his mouth and feasted on his tongue some
of them including the one in his mouth
burst upon reaching capacity he lost so
much blood that he began to get woozy
he fell over to the ground and rolled
over and over before passing out he saw
a figure this was it the shape-shifting
entity that takes the form of its
victims greatest fear as the figure drew
closer he saw its face was running
likewise sometimes it began to harden
and look like something or someone and
then it would start to run again
if it couldn't make up its mind who or
what it wanted to be I think that
Patrick was just so psychologically
messed up that it was unable to find
another fear for him that would be
suitable while there wasn't another form
that he feared he was afraid of an idea
which was the idea of death he believed
that if he died all others would die
because he was the only real person
I guess the leeches were a strong enough
form to do Patrick in them just goes to
show that even the craziest Psychopaths
have at least one thing that they're
afraid of it chills every time the
shape-shifting it's that only one thing
to him hello and goodbye before dragging
Patrick's body to the Barrens he passed
out on the way there when he awoke again
he was inside of the sewers it had
already begun feeding on him there's not
a whole lot more that I can say about
the life of Patrick Hawks Center we're
only given clues about the origin of his
saw lips ISM that put a dark cloud over
his youthful development and shaped him
into a homicidal sociopath on the way to
becoming a full-blown psycho as a
preteen however his issues started it's
clear that they continued because of his
increasing need to feed his addiction
the movies do paint Patrick to be a
sadistic character with some scary
issues but don't attempt to come close
to the dark and disturbing details of
Patrick's life in the novel hopefully
this analysis of him did him justice and
by the way let me know who else you'd
like to see covered here on horror
history or what franchise you'd like to
see me cover and if you haven't already
seen it the playlist on the Left
contains episodes on every other major
character and ends remember to subscribe
to seize these worlds for new Horrors
every week bring the death bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]